good afternoon if we can all take our
seats now for those of you in the back
there are seats available so please feel
free to come and sit down
I'm Kim Gough Cruz and as vice president
for student life and secretary of the
university it's my pleasure to welcome
all of you here in the audience and
those of you who are in the audience
live streaming to Yale's Veterans Day
service I would like to particularly
thank our dignitaries including the
Provost of the University of in Pollak
and of course mayor elect Tony Hart
who's joining us today we come together
today as others are doing all over the
country to honor those who have answered
the call to serve Yale men and women
have been conspicuous in that service
and we are honored to have among us
today veterans from our faculty staff
alumni and student body you're going to
hear today from three of those students
who have balanced their commitments to
their nation and to their studies at
Yale as they've articulated into the
Yale community of veteran scholars last
year as many of you know we welcomed
officially ROTC back to campus on this
very same Plaza and in the past year
students in uniform once a rarity
increasingly have become part of the
fabric of your life and I'm pleased to
see that some of our cadets and
Midshipmen are here with us along with
their commanding officers Colonel Scott
Manning of the Air Force and captain
Calvin Slocum of the Navy welcome
less visible but no less vital in their
contributions are the more than 60
veterans who are attending classes here
in the law school Divinity School and
graduate school in the schools of
Forestry and environmental studies
medicine management nursing public
health and Anil College to the prism of
their experiences our student veterans
enrich our lives daily both in the
classroom and outside of it
there are students like Alex Hawk who
you'll hear from in a few minutes when
he was growing up Alex wanted to be a
superhero
well Yale doesn't offer a major in that
particular field of study but alex has
still found role models in his life who
have taught him that not all superheroes
need a costume or a cape
Alex learned the unconventional way to
reach his goals a path that has taken
him to study as an eli whitney's student
in Yale College he is a certified
Department of Defense interrogator a
strategic debriefer and a military
source handler but not content with
merely fighting for freedom abroad
alex has also served at home to ensure
justice on the streets of the New York
of New York City as a part of the New
York City's Police Department then there
are students like Sara Barbra who will
also hear about from today she's a
student was nominated to speak by her
peers of the Yale student veterans
Council and Ananas Lee approved by the
Planning Committee for this event
today she will ask all of us to take
time to celebrate and to honor veterans
in our community during her time
commissioned with the Army Medical
Service Corps Sarah constantly felt
those two emotions as she cherished
being welcomed into a new family that of
the army family and she aimed to protect
those around her by training her fellow
colleagues
it is that generous and reflective
attitude that has carried her from her
first Veterans Day speech eight years
ago at her undergraduate alma mater the
University of Dayton across the ocean to
Iraq before coming here to Connecticut
to be with us today wherever she is
stationed Sara added more relations to
her ever-growing family and we are
privileged to be among them and then we
are also lucky because there are
students like Joel Johnson who's with us
today they dedicate themselves to their
country their studies and their families
a father of four Joel is pursuing a
master's degree in global affairs
through the Jackson Institute he has led
soldiers at the platoon and company
level through two deployments to Iraq
Joel currently is has just begun
training as a US farming US Army foreign
op area officer with Southeast Asia as
his regional focus these students are
but three voices in the larger veterans
community throughout campus veterans
play an instrumental role in our
day-to-day life whether they manage our
facilities plant they assist us in
setting up computers they teach courses
protect us as members of the police
department or administer programs and
services veterans serve and influence
the university at all levels few
ambassadors of the veterans community
reflect all that diversity more than
Reverend Harry Adams he has an alum of
the college in the Divinity School a
former dean of the Divinity School
chaplain of the University and a member
of the Yale bands most importantly he
could single-handedly perform all parts
of the ceremony today but he's an alum
who continues to incorporate the Yale
committee into his life when when he has
opportunities to interact with our
current veterans on campus fellowship at
Yale does not remain constrained within
borders it branches across all the
schools and all the departments at Yale
it intrudes traditional limitations of
hierarchy and it creates conversation
between faculty staff and students alike
it's George W Pearson famously described
the university yell is at once a
tradition a company of scholars a
society of friends our veterans
community resonates within that
University tradition of fellowship in
the past years we've seen the individual
veteran societies emerge in our
professional schools and our college
graduate schools all of these groups
assist student veterans in leveraging
their formal experiences to cultivate
camaraderie and Federer turnit II many
students participate in the Yale student
veterans Council which is one of our is
worked with us on the programming and
they incorporate the Yale tradition into
their goals by having meetings every
month at Morrie's the faculty and staff
joined the dialog through the veterans
VL Veterans Association which is also
one of our sponsors
it's all of these communities that make
me optimistic about continuing to make
yells culture and policies more veteran
friendly so let's continue to justify
that optimism let's continue to make
sure that all these conversations about
the future of our Republic today and
every day so that the ideals that
embodied by the service that have been
given by our students by our faculty and
staff and former generations include the
service of future generations and ours
it is now my distinct pleasure at this
time to call upon the officers from the
Yale University Police Department who
serve as our honor guard please stand as
they offer the presentation of colors
followed by the playing of our national
anthem and remain standing for
invocation
please bow your head with some heads
with me as I pray Heavenly Father we
humbly bow before you on this special
occasion as we honor the many service
men and women who have served the United
States and given their lives in its
defence we acknowledge your mighty hand
of protection over this country and its
brave men and women we thank you Lord
for the generations of men and women who
have fought to preserve our freedom
citizens who have been willing to face
terrible combat agonizing loneliness and
austere conditions in order to preserve
Liberty for their fellow Americans Lord
we thank you for providing America with
men and women of the highest character
once you never quit fighting for what is
right
even if it cost them their lives god we
humbly ask for your providence and grace
to remain over this country and that you
would continue to raise up courageous
Americans who will willingly give up
everything in order to protect the
freedoms which you have so graciously
granted to us we acknowledge your mighty
hand on this nation and its leaders and
we ask you to continue to guide us Lord
Heavenly Father we pray for your hedge
of protection around our soldiers
sailors airmen and Marines serving at
home and abroad lord provide our
servicemen and women with hope and dark
times peace after the fighting has
subsided and your favor upon them always
we ask for your perfect wisdom to guide
those in positions of authority within
the military so that they will lead
courageously and live as an example to
those who serve under them Lord for
those veterans who still deal with
painful reminders of their service we
ask that you would comfort them and
bring restoration we ask this for the
ones who have been crippled or wounded
in the service of this country as well
as for those who struggle to find peace
long after the battle has subsided for
veterans who still deal with
post-traumatic stress struggling to
sleep peacefully because of painful
memories we asked for you to intervene
and begin to heal these invisible scars
finally we remember those who have lost
sons or daughters husbands or wives
fathers or mothers and we asked
that you would send them your peace that
passes all understanding we humbly pray
these things in your mighty name Lord
God we thank you Heavenly Father for the
opportunity to come together to honor
those who have served this country those
who continue to serve and the ones who
have paid the highest price for the
liberties we still enjoy we ask that you
would bless this Veterans Day service
and all of us here today in Jesus name
we pray amen
please be seated
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen our
distinguished guests Provost [ __ ] and
mayor elect ARP our senior military
officers representing all branches of
the armed forces and all veterans both
present here and elsewhere thank you for
joining us today we are here today to
celebrate and to honor these are the
critical aspects of today's tribute
Veterans Day and contrast Memorial Day
it's not a solemn day of remembrance but
a celebration a day to honor all those
who have served in the Armed Forces to
celebrate and to honor eight years ago I
stood and delivered remarks for my
University's Veterans Day ceremony I was
a college senior in my final year of
ROTC and primary preparing to Commission
into the army it is interesting to think
about what has happened in eight years
since that speech I did in fact
commissioned as a Medical Service
Officer I went to training schools in
Georgia Texas California and Jordan I
was stationed in Colorado in Maryland my
combat Brigade deployed to southern Iraq
for a year all of that is on my official
record but it goes much further I
learned what it means to put yourself
put others before yourself I saw young
soldiers grow up and discover their
leadership potential I learned that a
hundred degrees Fahrenheit can actually
feel cold when your body is used to a
hundred and thirty
I had a pie thrown in my face on my very
first day of active duty later that
first day I felt the weight of real
responsibility when my new platoon
sergeant asked me if I could be trusted
upon to bring him back safely to his
wife and children I experienced
tremendous gratitude in heartbreaking
frustration sometimes on the same day I
sharply felt and will never doubt the
love and support of my family through an
outpouring of packages letters and Oreos
during deployment I gained another
family one forged by winter snow and
desert heat I learned what it means to
lose part of yourself and to find it
again
in the eight years since I gave that
first Veterans Day speech I commissioned
deployed lead learned mourned rejoiced
and
in short I became a veteran in doing so
I joined a proud line of public servants
that extends uninterrupted back further
than the formation of our country
spanning from the time of Nathan Hale
famed Continental Army officer and Yale
graduate up until right now with the
next generation of military leaders
before us in the ROTC program through
the centuries these Americans have stood
up to defend our country often at great
personal sacrifice for themselves and
their families I am honored to be
counted among the ranks there are 23
million veterans alive today in the u.s.
how best can we honor and celebrate them
for my part I wish to honor the veterans
who came before me who have worked to
improve the perception of soldiers
returning from war in Iraq I was
overwhelmed with the generosity and
support of the American people my
soldiers receive packages of
heartwarming cards from people we had
never met returning at the airport we
were given hugs and Cheers
I know that in large part this is from
the efforts of veterans who came before
us who fought different Wars and had
very different treatment upon return I'm
grateful to those who came before us who
work to ensure that people are separate
from politics and that soldiers
returning for more regarded as heroes
how else can we honor and celebrate my
suggestion is that one wonderful thing
you can do today to honor veterans is to
employ embody their values in your own
life I encourage you to think about what
can be learned about the values that
veterans live by about being part of
something bigger than yourself in a
military you take the time to make sure
the soldier next to you knows how to
shoot a weapon or inspect a vehicle or
how to operate a radio unity development
shared mission yes but also we take the
time because in the most literal of ways
we never know when our lives may depend
on the person next to us knowing how to
do his or her job what if we all live
like this like our lives depended on the
people next to us living up to their
potential and being equipped to fulfill
the best of themselves and contribution
to the betterment of our country and
humanity this Veterans Day I encourage
you to honor and celebrate the veterans
in your life send a package or send a
prayer to those deployed overseas are
those who have returned before whom the
physical and mental battle
not yet over and also celebrate by
embodying the best attributes of
veterans and bringing that message to
the rest of the world give up the
individual to contribute to the whole
believe in something much bigger than
yourself embrace diversity in your
organization's not only as a given but
as an absolute requirement to success be
grateful for every moment you are given
maintain perspective and know that
things could always be worse work for a
higher cause work for the person next to
you know that the work you do is not for
your own personal glory and success
before the success and forward momentum
of the United States and humanity this
is the legacy of American veterans and
this is what we honor and celebrate
today
thank you all for joining us today as we
celebrate our nation's heroes heroes is
a word you're gonna hear a lot today and
you always do about this time of year
and when I was growing up in Illinois I
thought I understood what it meant to be
a hero now I read about them in comic
books and I saw them on Saturday morning
cartoons and in their capes and costumes
heroes like Captain America and
superwoman
well they captivated my childhood
curiosities and dreams they were so
noble willing to stand against all evil
to ensure that good would triumph in the
world after all what little kid at least
I know I did every now and then I'd put
a pair of underwear on over my pants and
look up at the sky and pretend I could
fly right as I grew a little older I
came to know another kind of hero is I
got to be very close with my grandfather
my grandpa was drafted as an Army
infantryman in the Korean War the age of
18 he was asked to leave his wife his
family and his home and go fight for a
people that he had never met now about
halfway through his tour an enemy
grenade landed in his bunker the
explosion it sent the tons of sand and
dirt that he used for cover raining down
on top of him fellow soldiers witnessed
this and they expose themselves to enemy
fire to rush forward and dig through the
rubble with their bare hands
hoping to save his life luckily for me
they did and when he awoke a short while
later he was in a hospital in Japan he
found that his teeth and his skull had
been crushed by the weight of the debris
and his jaw was wired shut well the army
wanted to give a medal they wanted to
give him a Purple Heart but he declined
it immediately
because he thought that if you were to
accept it my grandmother might know that
he'd been injured he told me that in his
darkest moments he thought only of her
well my grandfather would have many dark
moments ahead because after two months
of eating through a straw the army sent
him back to the frontlines to finish his
tour my grandfather he didn't have any
superpowers he couldn't fly didn't wear
a cape he didn't hide behind a secret
identity but what he had was this
incredible public spirit he had the
ability to look beyond his own interests
and put the interests of his community
and his nation before his own as it
turns out this union disability is not
unique to my grandfather but it's been a
hallmark of military servicemembers for
centuries since our very beginning
American men and women have stood up to
fight for freedom and for justice some
like my grandpa did this in foreign
lands and for people they had never met
and others stood up to fight for
freedoms that they themselves couldn't
enjoy at home in 1776 there was Margaret
Corbin in the Battle of Fort Washington
she watched her husband die Manning an
artillery piece and then she stood up
and took over his fighting position and
rain fire down on the British gravely
wounded she became the first woman to
earn a full military pension it would be
over a hundred years before she would
learn the right to vote and then a
hundred years before the passing of the
Civil Rights Act that was Sergeant
William Carney sergeant Carney inspired
the 54th Massachusetts volunteers when
he picked up the Union colors and
charged into oncoming fire he had been
born a slave in Norfolk Virginia and
that act was the first act to iron an
African American the Congressional Medal
of Honor
and then there's my friend don't Tony
Greco
well Tony in 2009 was humiliated by our
armed forces when he was discharged
under Don't Ask Don't Tell yet Tony Toni
harbored no resentment and in 2011
one week after Don't Ask Don't Tell was
repealed Jiri enlisted and today as his
home state of Pennsylvania continues to
deny his right to marry Tony prepares to
go on a deployment to Afghanistan one of
the final of our nation Tony has chosen
service over self and these these
stories these veterans their courage
selflessness and love they inspire us
all and that's what superheroes do in
society's darkest days when sinister
forces seemed to be conspiring against
us threaten to take over the world
superheroes remind us that all is not
lost they remind us that while we might
not have superpowers ourselves when we
choose to overlook our own concerns and
stand together we can accomplish great
things
superheroes inspire hope so today I want
to say thank you to all the superheroes
that I never read about in comic books
to my grandpa to tony greco and to all
the men and women who have ever served
thank you
let us pray Almighty God as we remember
those who have served their country with
commitment and with curry we give thanks
for their dedication and sacrifice and
we pray your continued blessing upon our
nation and upon all the nations of our
world as we go from this place of
honored memory we beseech you to bless
us that we may strive with new
dedication for peace in our world and
for justice in our common life go in
peace amen
the colors are about to be retired and
as we conclude our Veterans Day program
you would like to thank the planning
committee for developing our program all
those who participate in the program as
well as Marge Berman who coordinated our
events today as we retire the program of
the colors we ask you to remain standing
and then we will be dismissed thank you
for joining us